biden's border crisis isn't just a
national security threat
it's now a public health disaster fox
news confirming tonight
via hhs that nearly 3 000
unaccompanied minors in their custody
have tested positive for covin
fox is also told that currently 319
coveted positive migrant youths
remain in isolation separately newsweek
discovered that 37 out of the 44 migrant
shelters in texas
have reported covet cases over the last
two weeks joining me now
stephen miller former white house senior
advisor to president trump
stephen now does mine believe that
being from central america would have
somehow made you
immune to the virus given how much the
restrictions are putting on us
the only way to explain this laura is
that the
bottom administration is under the
impression that only american citizens
and lawful residents are capable of
spreading govid
but that if you come across the border
illegally you inherit magical properties
that keep you from infecting others with
the coronavirus
i would also note those numbers are even
worse than they sound
because they're crammed together in such
close quarters that for everyone who
tests positive you can be
sure that the people that are released
around them will all be testing positive
in the days to follow um today the
chairman and ceo of gallup i mentioned
this to newt earlier
wrote this analysis of past polling data
33 countries in latin america and the
caribbean apparently
approximately roughly 450 million adults
live in the region
so gallup asked them if they'd like to
move to another country permanently
if they could of those who want to leave
their country permanently
35 or 42 million said they wanted to go
to the united states
so stephen essentially an open border
people walk in they're just taken care
of and are released into the country
what does that mean for us well it means
that
it means that we don't have a country
right now how many americans laura do
you think realized
when they were voting for joe biden they
were voting for
literally the end of nationhood as long
as joe biden's in office
having a country means that if you
trespass onto our territory
you are returned home politely humanely
but yes
you are returned home and it's not just
it's not just latin america this is a
global phenomenon
one of the things that i learned
firsthand on the front lines of the
border crisis
is that anyone in the world who can
afford a plane ticket
to panama afford a plane ticket to
guatemala
or to mexico city can then pay a
smuggler to get the rest
of the way to the u.s border so if you
don't have a firm repatriation policy
you're not just getting illegal aliens
from this hemisphere but from every
single
corner of planet earth and they'll just
keep coming and coming
and coming until the policy changes
well i have to say another point uh is
that biden
and president obrador from mexico they
seem to have
different views on who's responsible for
this current crisis
we'll share both sound bites back to
back watch
this new surge we're dealing with now
started with the last administration but
it's our responsibility
to deal with it humanely and to uh
and to stop what's happening
expectations were created
that with the government of president
biden there would be a better treatment
of migrants
and this has cost central american
migrants and also from our country
wanting to cross the border thinking
that it is easier to do so
so obrador is saying it's biden biden's
saying it's trump
well on this one i would definitely
trust operador i would actually point
out that amazingly
even though lopez obrador is a liberal
politician
on migration he's much more conservative
than joe biden he's far more opposed to
central americans illegally transiting
through the western hemisphere
and and from the rest of the world than
joe biden is and we said it before on
your program laura
but it has to be repeated endlessly
until the point gets across
when donald trump was in office if you
illegally brought a child to our country
if you illegally traffic the child to
our country
those individuals were still returned
back to their home country
shutting down those networks catch and
release was finished it was
done joe biden's decision to reopen
catch a release
is the sole exclusive singular reason
for this current crisis
uh yes or no will the media ask
questions about the border and will
guide and answer them tomorrow yes
no yes they'll ask them nobody won't am
i
urging to reporters if they if they
listen to me
my urging to them is ask follow-ups
don't just let biden waddle onto stage
with like four
question or four reporters pre-screened
he said oh i'm calling on you know
whatever list he's been given
by his staff if you're in that room ask
a question
if he doesn't answer ask a follow-up and
another follow-up
you're entitled to we gotta roll ask the
follow-ups